Tim Legler ESPN NBA analyst and analyst
for SportsCenter throughout the NBA
Finals and legs joins us on the program
legs thanks for joining us let me start
with this will there or should there be
an asterisk by this NBA Finals
absolutely not no and I think Dan if
we're really going to go back and take a
look at you know the last 30 NBA
champions there's a lot more things than
that you would find if you're going to
start digging into who's healthy who's
hurt what teams were missing at certain
times I get in a moment it's going to be
talked about because these aren't just
two injuries these are two catastrophic
injuries I mean this is these are two of
the big three when you talk about NBA
injuries right the ACL the Achilles and
I guess the patellar tendon would be the
third one so these are catastrophic I
get it these are these are you know the
two names that they are so in a moment
we're going to focus on it certainly in
a Bay Area they're going to be talking
about this for a long time but it goes
away
and you don't talk about anymore and I
think ultimately a couple years from now
or when you reflect back on this title
20 years from now they're going to the
visualization you're going to have is
the dominance of Kawhi Leonard that's
all you're gonna remember when you go
back to this team and winning this title
because this was one of the most
dominant and consistent and machine-like
playoff performances in NBA history and
you know I just I was amazed and
watching this guy play every night and
how much he has improved his game most
of his career what does it say about the
NBA and maybe this is an anomaly but you
didn't have anybody drafted higher than
fourth overall playing in the NBA Finals
except for Kevin Durant
I think boogy cousins with fifth overall
but everybody else is either in the
lottery later on first or second round
or not even drafted at all I think
that's a good thing right I mean it's it
shows that well first of all about
Golden State already for you giving them
credit for that and the way they built
team it was a homegrown thing for the
most part until KD got there they had
already won a championship
before he arrived you know be and they
did it by drafting those guys you know
getting draymond a second round pick up
klay Thompson curry even Harrison Barnes
who was key part of those early teams
you drafted yourself so they did it in a
homegoing way so give them credit for
identifying the talent the same thing
when you look at the Toronto Raptors
that a lot of these guys clean with
other places but they drafted Pascal
siakam I mean he's a guy that they
identified early on and you look at the
growth and emergence of him
there's another guy that put his stamp
now is going to be an all four caliber
player going favorite that they
identified they don't win a championship
dish without Pascal siakam so I think a
good thing overall for the NBA and I
think it's good to look at guys and give
them credit for turning themselves into
players that we watched during this
Finals particularly guy like Kauai was a
baseline slapper a decent mid-range jump
shooter did not Efrain point range was
not a good ball handler when he came
into the NBA and now this guy is
controlling entire games of the trap
students with his hands on his physical
strength and his precision on his
shooting and he became automatic at the
foul line and impression movements as
well so cannot say enough about what
this guy did and how fun it was to watch
him and also think by the ways I love
the role model that he is in terms of
his demeanor on the court uh you know I
think there's something good about guys
that don't celebrate themselves and they
just go about their job and go about
their business and they keep that stoic
demeanor I think that's a good thing and
I think it's something that more young
players should be shown and say this is
a good thing you see how he's always in
control with his emotions he's not
trying to bring attention to himself
it's all about getting the job done I
just really admire that what about his
work knowing what we know now and don't
know now who would you say is the team
to beat next season goodness gracious
you know this is such a tough question
to answer because of who we're talking
about in the potential that you guys
change teams I mean look at the
possibilities and who ends up where and
how dramatically different the answer to
that question would be a clearly Golden
State it's not going to be in that
category because you you're not going to
see Kevin Durant I'm guessing all next
year based on what we know now about
clay
said you know at best you're looking at
a guy coming back right before the
playoff do you really want to do that to
a guy for open ACL reconstruction and
put them through a two-month playoff
grind there's a good chance we don't see
you don't know those guys next year
maybe they should tell Steph Curry to go
away for a year just go to an island
somewhere and rest your body and have
all three of those guys come back
together if you can respond you're an so
and I don't think Golden State's in that
category it's just based on what they're
going to be facing from an injury
standpoint um you know Kawhi Leonard I
still think it's a coin toss whether he
comes back or not everybody seems to
think it's a foregone conclusion he's
going I don't know I think some of the
things you said last night we're telling
you know he's talked about the
connection the guys had in the locker
room and how no one had any egos there
was no problem personal clashes between
anybody I don't think he was necessarily
taking his shot at anybody in San
Antonio I think he was just reflecting
on the health of this situation I think
that's really important to a guy like
Kawhi Leonard because it doesn't require
as much verbal and vocal leadership when
you've got it healthy locker room and I
think that's what he's all about
just show up do my job because there's
no fires to put out amongst my own team
I think that's kind of what he was
saying last night so I think that's a
coin toss but he stays so what we know
the Toronto Raptors would be I think the
favorite going in because there could be
so such a different look for teams like
New York or the nets or the clippers or
Lakers where's Anthony Davis going to go
you know so that there's so many
unanswered questions of going into this
season let's just say Kawhi Leonard
stays in the Toronto Raptors are the
most surefire bet he's Tim Legler ESPN
NBA analyst right quick
quick hitters here if you're Kawhi
Leonard what do you do today if I'm
Kawhi Leonard I stay if you ran the
pelicans you got a booth Anthony Davis
including the trading deadline did he
get that pick on her ass tonight I'm
sorry for that the draft because you
need that pick on draft night I think
the best assets you can get our probably
in process but he's saying no way am i
reciting and it's incumbent upon you
probably because I just don't know if
they want to do business with that team
if you were Kevin Durant
hmm stay I'm Kevin Durant I'm staying
there but I don't think is going to if
not there then where the Knicks it seems
like he's had the Knicks and hand Kyrie
parent up in New York seems very likely
although I'm hearing bored bored a child
like you had at the Brooklyn you know
it's hard to know hard to gauge these
guys legs good stuff great stuff during
the season and you know your playoff
breakdown
we're wonderful in sports center so
great to connect with you again and we
appreciate your time thanks it's always
great talk that's Tim Legler one of the
great shooters NBA history legs does
agree very bright when it comes to
breaking down plays like plays that can
you know determine who wins and who
loses he was very good during the
playoff run here on SportsCenter for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]